[Música]
olá meu nome é laura tenho dez anos e
hoje vou falar sobre moda sustentável
você já pensou de onde vêm as suas
roupas
muitas vezes elas podem prejudicar o
meio ambiente por exemplo veja como o
processo de tingimento de tecidos pode
ser sujo
é claro que se pode prejudicar o meio
ambiente moda sustentável é criar roupas
se preocupando com a sustentabilidade
por exemplo existem lojas que eram
roupas feitas com materiais 100%
naturais e que são renováveis
existem vários tipos de materiais
sustentáveis que podemos usar para criar
roupas em prejudicar o ambiente
alguns deles são retalhos de tecidos
utilizados materiais que iriam para o
lixo embalagens tivemos nosso dia-a-dia
materiais renováveis e fibras naturais
[Música]
muitas vezes nós inclusive nós
consumimos demais comprando por impulso
nos preocupando com o nosso planeta
evite comprar tudo que você vê pela
frente têm de comprar somente o
necessário
mas pense e se você usar aquele vestido
lindo que sai de moda mais que você
adora ou invés de cobrar que o vestido
que está na moda que todo mundo só que
você não gosta ponto ao invés de comprar
roupas novas todo mês
hoje é só porque você já tem elenco
desse tem o seu próprio estilo
você não precisa estar sempre na moda se
você gosta de uma roupa que está fora de
moda tudo bem de gosto não se discute
para essa apresentação e fez uma roupa
sustentável para dar um exemplo de como
ajudar nosso planeta já que as
indústrias em geral não só de roupas
podem acabar com a natureza
essa é a agir
e ela tá aí a roupa sustentável a minha
roupa é sustentável
a minha roupa feita de fuxicos que quase
uma flor feita de tecido ela sustentável
pois quando se fecha os chicos você
utiliza reutilizar os retalhos de
tecidos que seriam jogados fora e não
daria para fazer mais nada
obrigada
[Aplausos]